[Musica]
la prima volta è stato circa due
settimane fa stavamo cenando a casa mia
moglie ed io ed i nostri tre figli di 24
21 e 15 anni e ci divertivamo chiedendo
l'assistente vocale di mettere una
canzone scelta a turno da ciascuno di
noi
ad un certo punto squilla il mio
cellulare
la telefonata è importante chiedo
l'assistente vocale di interrompere la
musica la risposta mi congela mi
dispiace preferisco continuare ad
aiutarti noi cinque ci guardiamo e so
che veniamo attraversati tutti dallo
stesso pensiero hal 9000 il computer di
2001 odissea nello spazio e tra noi
l'incubo è cominciato quella notte non
ci ho dormito
ho cominciato a pensare che quelle
riflessioni che han e maturo esperto
giurista notaio sembravano formulate da
geek e nerd poco più che adolescenti sul
futuro della mia professione sul futuro
della professione di giurista forse
meritassero qualche attenzione in più mi
frullava in testa tre domande che adesso
ripropongo a voi ma vi piacerebbe essere
difesi da un computer
sareste tranquilli se foste giudicati da
una macchina mi farebbe piacere sapere
che il vostro testamento o il vostro
atto di acquisto della prima casa sono
stati redatti da un robot pensate che
esistono sondaggi in cui la maggioranza
degli intervistati a queste domande ha
risposto affermativamente
io credo che però per non rispondere in
modo istintivo a queste domande ma
ponderato riflessivo
occorre porsi qualche altra domanda
preventiva e cioè innanzitutto occorre
chiedersi che cos'è il diritto il
diritto è una struttura o meglio
un'infrastruttura che regola l'ordinato
svolgimento della vita di una comunità
in sostanza il diritto non rende il
mondo più giusto ma un mondo senza
diritto sarebbe incommensurabilmente più
complesso e più difficile di quello che
è una una società senza diritto sarebbe
così disfunzionale così disorganizzata
da non poter avere alcuna possibilità di
sopravvivenza e quindi a cosa serve il
diritto beh gli uomini hanno desideri
hanno bisogni che tendono a soddisfare
rivolgendosi verso beni i beni che però
non sono infiniti questa tensione verso
i beni che gli uomini hanno per
realizzare i propri bisogni e propri
desideri si chiama interesse il diritto
serve a regolare gli interessi degli
esseri umani che si rivolgono verso gli
stessi beni quando questi interessi sono
rivolti verso stessi beni da parte degli
stessi soggetti può nascere un
potenziale conflitto e il diritto serve
a regolare questi conflitti
ebbene chi è che si occupa di diritto i
giuristi e che si può fregiare
dell'appellativo di giurista avvocati
magistrati notai e i giuristi nella
nostra società sono dappertutto
molti vorrebbero che di giuristi si
facesse a meno sono convinti che dei
giuristi si potrebbe fare a meno
ed invece non esiste questioni di
maggiore o minore importanza per la
quale non ci si rivolga a un giurista
per avere la sua opinione
per sapere come la risolverebbe
nonostante questa assoluta necessità di
rivolgere i giuristi i giuristi sono
convinti e hanno il terrore
di essere oggi sostituiti
dall'intelligenza artificiale intesa
come insieme di tecnologie in cui le
macchine che oggi hanno la facoltà di
agire di comprendere e soprattutto di
apprendere possano in definitiva
sostituirli al punto che si arrivi a non
aver più bisogno di loro
considerati inutili e costosi ma io
credo che per poter capire se davvero la
sentenza l'atto notarile la difesa
l'assistenza legale siano soltanto un
prodotto che nasce dalla inserzione di
una gran mole di dati dentro una
macchina che a quel punto sputa una
risposta
io credo che ci si debba chiedere che
cosa fanno i giuristi
beh l'avvocato domanda ascolta consiglia
e difende il notaio domanda ascolta e
traduce quell'ascolto in un documento il
giudice domanda e decide
credo che sia chiaro che quello che
accomuna i giuristi e il fatto che tutti
pongono domande i computer le macchine
sfornano risposte dopo pablo picasso in
un'intervista ebbe a dire i computer
sono inutili sanno soltanto dare
risposte
ecco questa è la sostanziale differenza
tra l'uomo e la macchina perché i
computer
la macchina non sa quali siano le
domande importanti non sa quali siano le
domande le cui risposte possono portare
alla decisione corretta
e se questo è il derivato della mente
umana per cui la decisione la sentenza
l'atto non risulta unicamente dall
insieme di dati che vengono inseriti
anche nel cervello umano
esattamente come vengono
inseriti nella macchina ma gli input che
il cervello umano riceve sono anche
quelli che derivano dalle risposte che
conseguono le giuste domande
c'è da chiedersi come si fa a porre le
domande corrette quelle che porta a
quelle risposte attraverso la
comunicazione
questo perché la comunicazione giuridica
si basa sulla comunicazione naturale in
cui ogni termine non ha un significato
rigorosamente univoco ma non soltanto la
comunicazione giuridica come in realtà
la comunicazione umana in genere non si
basa soltanto sul verbale cioè su quello
che dico ma anche sul come lo dico
la comunicazione paraverbale il tono il
volume il ritmo ma soprattutto si basa
sul linguaggio del corpo sul non verbale
il look la mimica facciale la postura la
gestualità la prossemica la capacità di
leggere il linguaggio del corpo porta il
giurista non soltanto a formulare le
domande giuste ma leggere nella mente le
suo cliente a leggere nella mente
dell'imputato fino ad arrivare a capire
quali sono le sue reali esigenze fino ad
arrivare a capire se è sincero o se sta
mentendo il diritto quindi e si tecnica
è sì competenza e si capacita di
utilizzo degli strumenti tecnologici ma
è anche e soprattutto comprensione ed
ecco perché il giurista umano quello che
arriva alla risposta alla decisione
all'atto alla sentenza attraverso questo
processo di comunicazione rimarrà e
rimane insostituibile
il cervello umano non è in grado
sicuramente di processare dati in un
nanosecondo come fanno le macchine ma
attraverso il cervello umano che il
magistrato
il giudice riesce a proporre una
sentenza
giudica una controversia in modo
innovativo rispetto ai precedenti
giurisprudenziali è il cervello umano
che porta
l'avvocato a far prendere in
considerazione da una corte ea far
tutelare un diritto che fino ad allora
non aveva meritato tutela è quella forma
di comunicazione che consente al notaio
avendo ascoltato i suoi clienti di
proporre un atto atipico
a questo punto vorrei provare a
riformulare v le domande che ci siamo
posti all'inizio mi piacerebbe essere
giudicati da un computer
sareste tranquilli se la vostra difesa
venisse assunta da una macchina avreste
piacere che il vostro testamento o
l'atto di acquisto della vostra prima
casa venissero redatti stipulati da un
robot io credo di no ma se a questo
punto le vostre risposte a queste
domande sono ancora affermative io vi
chiedo il vostro computer avrebbe saputo
come fece come seppe fare enzo tortora
nel momento di chiusura della
requisitoria rivolta ai suoi giudici a
difesa di se stesso voi mi chiedete ed
io dovrei dire ho fiducia
allora vi ribalto la domanda avreste
fiducia voi io sono innocente lo grido
da dieci anni lo gridano le carte io mi
auguro dal profondo del cuore che siate
innocenti anche voi la vostra macchina
avrebbe saputo per descrivere i termini
giuridici l'olocausto per descrivere i
crimini commessi durante il nazismo
coniare la parola genocidio per poter
descrivere i crimini contro l'umanità
commessi a danno di gruppi
razziali religiosi culturali coniare un
termine come genocidio che deriva dal
greco ghenos razza stirpe e dal latino
cedere uccidere coniare un termine di
questa portata che venne introdotto
negli atti d'accusa di quel processo
svoltosi a norimberga contro i criminali
nazisti e che portò a condannare per
crimini contro l'umanità quei gerarchi
l'avrebbe saputo fare una macchina
no per quel termine si batte fortemente
un avvocato di nome raphael lemkin il
vostro robot avrebbe saputo scrivere un
testamento così come seppe fare luigi
pirandello sia lasciata passare in
silenzio la mia morte
messa volga nudo in un lenzuolo il mio
corpo venga arso e le mie ceneri
disperse
perché nulla neanche le ceneri devono
lasciare traccia di me io credo che la
vostra macchina il vostro robot il
vostro computer questo non l'avrebbe
saputo fare
hal 9000 forse è entrato nella mia casa
ma è ancora molto lontano dal mio studio
grazie